Prince have a club in his house Prince
came over and said hey but he you know
princess shot so he I didn't know I just
heard this noise behind me and I didn't
know what it was he just trying to get
my attention he was like
so I turned around I was like Hey Prince
he's small so I was like Hey Prince how
you doing licking on his fingers when he
was talking to me I was kind of he was
like how you doing you like the show as
a girl
thank you for coming Chris I love you
you hang out with Michael Jackson we
bump into each other around the world
man it's like and he's cool because he
called me sometimes check up on me see
how I'm doing he's like how you doing
Chris
we go to the movies but it's hard
because Michael got to sneak in the
movie right before it start so Michael
coming in like with a ninja suit on he's
hiding and all black all of a sudden I'm
sitting there where's Michael and then I
turn around he's like hey Chris I'm like
oh man we watching the movie he's the
loudest person in there really yeah he's
watching movies like hey
laughs